From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Nancy Updike, sitting in for Ira Glass.
来自芝加哥WBEZ广播电台，这里是《美国生活》。我是南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike），今天代班艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。
OK, Val, what are we looking at?
好的，瓦尔，我们现在在看什么？
So this video, it's from the front lines of the war in Ukraine. It's from a few weeks ago and it's in Bakhmut, which is a city in the eastern part of the country. And the video is shot by this guy who's part of a team of volunteers who help people get out. He's filming it on a camera that's inside his front coat pocket or something.
这段视频拍摄于乌克兰战争的前线。它是几周前拍摄的，地点在乌克兰东部的巴赫穆特。视频是一个志愿者团队的成员拍摄的，他们专门负责协助平民撤离。拍摄者把相机放在了大衣的前口袋里，或者是类似的地方。
Yeah, I can tell it's kind of herky-jerky because he's running. Now he's walking, actually. There are low buildings all around, like, three or four stories.
是的，我看得出来画面有点晃动，因为他在奔跑。哦，现在他改成了快走。周围都是些低矮的建筑，大概三四层楼高。
Yeah, and there are no people in sight.
没错，而且视野里一个人也没有。
Evacuatziyu.
撤离。
No cars-- it's totally empty.
没有车，街道完全是空的。
All right, I'm going to stop here for some quick background. Valerie, who's been talking me through the video, is my colleague, Valerie Kipnis, a producer at the show. She speaks Russian, understands Ukrainian. She has been watching a lot of these videos, which are a genre in this war.
好了，我要在这里暂停一下，先提供一点背景信息。刚才为我解读视频的瓦莱丽（Valerie）是我的同事，瓦莱丽·基普尼斯（Valerie Kipnis），也是节目的制作人。她懂俄语，也听得懂乌克兰语。她一直在关注这类视频，这在当前的战争中已经成为一种特殊的影像类型。
In Bakhmut, the fighting has been terrible for months. The city may already have fallen by the time this airs. Tens of thousands of people left the city in earlier waves. The deputy prime minister of Ukraine said the other week, quote, "If you are rational, law abiding, and patriotic citizens, you should leave the city immediately."
在巴赫穆特，战斗已经惨烈地持续了数月。等到节目播出时，这座城市可能已经陷落。数以万计的人早在之前的几波撤离中离开了这里。乌克兰副总理上周表示：“如果你是理性的、守法的、爱国的公民，你应该立即撤离这座城市。”
But at every front line, in every war, if it's a city, there are people holding out. In Bakhmut, maybe several thousand, many elderly or disabled people, those caring for them, also diehards. And so ordinary people, like the guy who shot this video, have taken it upon themselves to put on bulletproof vests, somehow get into Bakhmut, and get people out, take them to a refugee center where they'll be safe.
但在每一场战争的每一个前线，只要是城市，就总有人坚持留守。在巴赫穆特，或许还有几千人，其中许多是老人或残疾人，还有照顾他们的人，当然也有死硬派。于是，像视频里的拍摄者这样的普通人，主动承担起重任，穿上防弹背心，设法进入巴赫穆特，把人们带出来，送往安全的难民中心。
All right, back to this video that Valerie is showing me. The volunteer, a guy named Kuba, is in Bakhmut, looking for an older woman, who seems to be one of the last people left in this one apartment building. OK, he's running up the stairs.
好了，回到瓦莱丽给我看的这段视频。这位名叫库巴（Kuba）的志愿者正在巴赫穆特寻找一位老妇人，她似乎是这栋公寓楼里最后留守的人之一。好了，他正跑上楼梯。
And you can see this building is totally destroyed. You can barely see it but it has a huge hole in it.
你可以看到这栋楼已经彻底被毁了。几乎看不出来原貌，上面有一个巨大的洞。
[RUSSIAN SPEECH]
[俄语对话]
He's shouting, evacuation, evacuators.
他在喊：撤离，撤离。
I see.
明白了。
And so he's trying to shout, hey--
他试图喊：嘿——
[RUSSIAN SPEECH]
[俄语对话]
--come out.
——出来。
[RUSSIAN SPEECH]
[俄语对话]
[DOOR OPENING]
[开门声]
[RUSSIAN SPEECH]
[俄语对话]
Oh, there she is. He found her.
哦，找到了。他找到她了。
And he's saying, hey, I'm a volunteer. My name's Kuba. I'm here to take you out. I'm here to take you to peace. And she's like, I'm not ready. I'm not ready. I'm not packed. And he's like, there's lots of bombs. We have to go.
他在说：嘿，我是志愿者，我叫库巴。我来接你离开。我来带你去安全的地方。而她说：我还没准备好。我没准备好，我还没收拾行李。他说：有很多炸弹，我们必须得走。
There's clearly no heat. She's in a coat and a hat, and she's got her glasses.
很明显屋里没有暖气。她穿着大衣和帽子，还戴着眼镜。
[RUSSIAN SPEECH]
[俄语对话]
She's like, what do I take with me? And he's like, passports and pictures of loved ones. That's it, let's go. And she's saying, I need to pack grapes, and maybe some sort of pancakes, or chocolate. And he's like, there's going to be everything there. Come.
她说：我该带什么走？他说：带上护照和亲人的照片就行。就这些，快走吧。她说：我得带上葡萄，也许还有某种煎饼，或者巧克力。他说：那边什么都有。快来。
And then the video jumps ahead, and suddenly, they are outside walking.
接着视频跳到了后面，他们突然已经在外面走路了。
[RUSSIAN SPEECH]
[俄语对话]
She goes, I got less ready than I would have if there was a fire.
她说：我这次收拾行李比失火时还仓促。
[RUSSIAN SPEECH]
[俄语对话]
And she goes, and my shoes are all broken. They're all falling apart.
她说：而且我的鞋全破了，都要散架了。
[RUSSIAN SPEECH]
[俄语对话]
What am I going to wear there?
我到那边穿什么呢？
[RUSSIAN SPEECH]
[俄语对话]
And he's like, there will be everything there.
他说：那边一切都会有的。
[RUSSIAN SPEECH]
[俄语对话]
There will be everything.
一切都会有的。
And how many of his videos have you watched?
你看了他多少视频了？
Oh, man, dozens? Over 100?
天哪，几十个？有一百多个了吧？
These evacuations are a whole thing that's happening. There are loose networks of people who do it. There's no one organization behind it, but evacuators just go in, like this guy, Kuba. Sometimes he gets into town and all he has is a name, maybe from a family member who contacted him, like, can you get out my grandma or my cousin? Maybe he has an address if the person is still there. And if Kuba can't find it or he's running out of time, he just jogs through the streets, calling their name out.
这些撤离行动现在规模很大。有一群松散的人在做这件事。背后没有统一的组织，但像库巴这样的撤离人员就会直接进去。有时他进城时只知道一个名字，可能是联系他的家人提供的，比如，“你能带我祖母或表亲离开吗？”也许他能拿到地址，如果那人还在的话。如果库巴找不到地方或者时间紧迫，他就会一边穿过街道，一边大声呼喊他们的名字。
Lilia! Lilia!
莉莉娅！莉莉娅！
[DOG BARKING]
[狗叫声]
Lilia!
莉莉娅！
The problem is, people don't always want to go. A lot of people he meets don't want to go. They're not ready, or they don't want to be rescued. Some don't want to leave property, or they don't want to abandon other family members who won't leave.
问题是，人们并不总是想走。他遇到的人中很多都不想离开。他们没准备好，或者不想被救援。有些人不想丢下财产，或者不想抛下其他不愿意离开的家人。
Some think the worst is over or will soon be over, and that once one side or the other wins, everything will calm down, and they'll just learn to live with the outcome, whatever that is. Valerie's been talking with this guy, Kuba Stasiak, who works in the east, including Bakhmut. He's a young man, 28. He's Polish. His group has people from all over, including Ukrainians. Kuba says when he's trying to persuade people to go, sometimes maps help.
有些人认为最坏的时刻已经过去，或者很快就会结束，只要某一方赢了，一切都会平静下来，他们就能学会适应结果，无论那是什么。瓦莱丽一直在与这位库巴·斯塔西亚克（Kuba Stasiak）交流，他在东部包括巴赫穆特地区工作。他是个28岁的波兰年轻人。他的团队成员来自各地，包括乌克兰人。库巴说，当他试图劝说人们离开时，地图有时能派上用场。
I show them that Russians are pushing from every single direction that they can, and in a couple of days there will be nothing. And that on the next day, there may be-- I mean, there is a risk that tomorrow we won't reach their house because Russians will cut off the last road.
我会给他们展示，俄军正从他们能到达的每一个方向推进，再过几天这里就什么都没有了。而且到明天，可能——我是说，真的有风险，明天我们就无法到达他们的房子了，因为俄军会切断最后一条道路。
Kuba told Valerie that when he started doing this almost a year ago, he wanted to convince every person he talked to to leave. But he's gotten very used to hearing no.
库巴告诉瓦莱丽，当他近一年前开始做这件事时，他想说服他交谈的每一个人离开。但他现在已经习惯了听到“不”。
Because back then, I was trying to convince anyone, anytime. And right now, when there is a heavy shelling and somebody is telling me to, pardon my French, [BLEEP]. I'm just, like, whatever, of course. Yeah.
因为当时我试图说服每一个人，随时随地都在劝。但现在，当炮击很严重，有人对我说“去他妈的”（原谅我粗俗）时，我只会觉得，好吧，随你便。
Sure, you can't help anybody, especially when they are just hostile towards you. You can't do nothing. And it's naive to think, to believe that you can, because you can't. You just can't save the whole world, that's what I'm trying to say.
当然，你帮不了任何人，尤其是当他们对你充满敌意的时候。你什么也做不了。如果认为自己能救下所有人，那是天真，因为你做不到。我想说的是，你不可能拯救整个世界。
Even some yeses, he's found, are kind of a no. That woman he evacuated, who wanted to pack up grapes and pancakes, Valerie says he took her to a refugee center in a city called Kramatorsk.
他发现，即使是答应的人，有时也并不真心。瓦莱丽说，他把那个想打包葡萄和煎饼的妇女送到了克拉马托尔斯克的一家难民中心。
It's about an hour away from her home, and she was so upset, Kuba told me.
那里离她家大约有一个小时的路程，库巴告诉我，她非常难过。
She wasn't happy about the leave. She asked me, I mean, why did I took her to such a wild place? She had this perspective that I, I don't know, tricked her or something, so she was upset. She was telling me that she wants to go back. And I was like, but the city is dying. City is kaput.
她对离开很不高兴。她问我，为什么要带她到这种荒凉的地方？她觉得我——我不知道——骗了她之类的，所以她很生气。她告诉我说她想回去。我说，但这城市正在死去。城市已经完了。
And she was like, OK, so I will die with the city. And I was like, OK. End of conversation. What can I do?
她说，好吧，那我就和这座城市一起死。我说，好吧。对话结束。我还能做什么？
And they kind of lost touch for a little bit, and it turns out that she ended up having her relatives send her back East, to a Russian occupied area, where maybe it's not the front line, but it's due to be dangerous soon. And Kuba, after he heard that, he went back to her house just to look at it. And he saw--
他们后来断了联系，结果她最后竟然让亲戚送她回到了东部，回到了俄军占领区，那里也许不是前线，但很快也会变得危险。库巴听到这个消息后，回去看了看她的房子。他看到——
The house he evacuated her from?
就是他把她救出来的那个房子？
That's right. And he went to look at it and he saw that, specifically, her apartment had been destroyed by another strike. And I think he felt sort of this sense of validation, like, you would have been killed if I had not taken you out. But she was still sort of unhappy and ended up going back to an occupied region.
没错。他去看的时候，发现她的公寓被另一轮袭击摧毁了。我想他当时有一种验证感，就好像，如果我没把你救出来，你就已经没命了。但她依然很不高兴，最终回到了被占领区。
What did she mean, a wild place?
她说“荒凉的地方”是什么意思？
I think she meant that it wasn't home. That's what I really think she meant.
我觉得她的意思是那不是家。我真的觉得她是这个意思。
But this show is not going to be about nos or yeses. It's about people weighing when to go. And one reason Kuba and others go back to the same city again and again is that sometimes a person who's been a no, no, no, no, no, for months, is suddenly a yes, please. It is time.
但本期节目不打算只讨论“不”或“是”。它讨论的是人们权衡何时离开的心理。库巴和其他人反复回到同一座城市的一个原因就是，有时那些几个月来一直回答“不，不，不，不，不”的人，突然会说“好，拜托了”。是时候了。
Valerie managed to reach someone Kuba helped get out of Bakhmut two months ago. That man, Roman, had been living there with his parents, who were in their 70s. And he told Valerie what changed for him because he actually first met Kuba months ago and was like, nah, we're good, even though things were bad.
瓦莱丽联系上了两个月前库巴从巴赫穆特救出的一位人士。那个人叫罗曼（Roman），之前和70多岁的父母住在那。他告诉瓦莱丽是什么让他改变了主意，因为他其实几个月前就见过库巴，当时他说，“不，我们挺好的”，尽管情况已经很糟糕了。
[RUSSIAN SPEECH]
[俄语对话]
I almost got killed nine times in Bakhmut. I got caught in gunfire. I got caught in explosions in the center of the city while I was crossing the Nikolaevsky Bridge, even there I almost died.
在巴赫穆特我差点死了九次。我遭遇过枪击。我在市中心穿过尼古拉耶夫斯基桥时遇到了爆炸，在那儿我都差点没命。
And in a home I almost died. It was really serious. I'm telling you, nine times. I was even talking to Ukrainian military and I was telling them, I kind of got used to it already. And they said, that's a bad habit.
在家里我也差点没命。真的很严重。我告诉你，九次。我甚至对乌克兰军队说，我好像已经习惯了。他们说，这可是个坏习惯。
[RUSSIAN SPEECH]
[俄语对话]
And then things got worse, and worse, and worse, and all of a sudden, the telephone wires by our house were all dangling. And then I saw that there was gunfire on the houses, on the roads, on the fences. And then I just went outside of my house and I just saw the bullets ricocheting.
后来情况越来越糟，突然间，房子旁边的电话线都垂了下来。我看到房子、马路上、栅栏上全是弹痕。我走到屋外，看见子弹在反弹。
And I just thought, that's it. I don't think we'll make it. And I started talking to my parents, I just don't think we'll make it. And I told them, we got to do something. It's either we leave, or we die.
那一刻我想，完了。我觉得我们撑不下去了。我开始和父母沟通，我觉得我们撑不过去了。我告诉他们，我们必须做点什么。要么离开，要么死。
They decided to go. And there's a video of this evacuation, too, Roman and his parents. Roman's father seems very frail. In the video, one of the evacuators is helping his father shuffle backward over this metal beam that's a makeshift bridge over a river.
他们决定离开。这次撤离也有视频记录，罗曼和他的父母。罗曼的父亲看起来非常虚弱。视频中，一名撤离人员正帮助他父亲在金属梁上一步步后退，那是一座横跨河流的简易桥。
The father is holding on and moving very slowly.
父亲紧紧抓着，移动得非常缓慢。
[RUSSIAN SPEECH]
[俄语对话]
And there was an explosion. It was all black, and it was just like, the house over, my neighbor's house, that it fell, the missile. And then, when we got out of there, I just said, wow, look how quiet it is. You can actually be here. You could just sit here and relax, and it was just like, it was where we lived that they were attacking.
然后发生了爆炸。周围一片漆黑，就像，隔壁邻居的房子，导弹落下了。当我们逃出来的时候，我只是说，哇，看这里多安静。你真的可以待在这里。你可以坐在这里休息，但这正是我们居住的地方，而他们正在攻击那里。
And then, when I got to Kramatorsk, I started looking around and I saw civilization, and light, electricity, and the trolley buses working. And I just felt this sense of elation, a smile cross my face, or something. Actually, the first time that they took these cookies out onto the table, I just-- I felt so happy. It had been so long since I had even seen them.
后来，当我到达克拉马托尔斯克，我环顾四周，看到了文明，有灯光，电力，电车在运行。我感受到一种狂喜，脸上露出了笑容，什么的。其实，当他们第一次把那些饼干放到桌上时，我——我感到太开心了。我已经很久没见过它们了。
Do you understand? I hadn't seen loaves of bread. Sure, I had coffee, but still, that was hard to come by, and cookies. And I had forgotten what that tasted like, and it just felt so amazing to have them finally.
你明白吗？我连面包都没见过。当然，我有咖啡，但那也很难得，还有饼干。我已经忘了那是什么味道了，最后能吃到它们，感觉真是太棒了。
[RUSSIAN SPEECH]
[俄语对话]
But to be totally honest, I still yearn to go to my place, to my home.
但说实话，我还是很渴望回到我的地方，回到我的家。
Today's show-- "When To Leave." How do you know when it's right to make a decision that is so often full of doubt, guilt, consequences for other people?
今天的节目主题——“何时离开”。当你面临一个充满疑虑、负罪感和对他人的影响的决定时，你怎么知道什么时候才是正确的时机？
And even afterward, sometimes forever afterward, regret and longing, and second guesses. We have two stories today with high stakes and complicated choices. Stay with us.
甚至在事后，有时是永远地，你还会感到后悔、渴望和事后猜测。今天我们有两个故事，涉及高风险和复杂的选择。请继续收听。
Act One, First, Do No Harm. Let's start right in, with a calm, rational person assessing a new reality, getting a feel for what it means, and deciding what to do. Miki Meek reports.
第一幕，首先，不伤害（First, Do No Harm）。让我们直接开始，看看一个冷静、理性的专业人士如何评估新的现实，感受其含义，并决定该做什么。米基·米克（Miki Meek）报道。
Amelia Huntsberger has a story she tells about what it's like to work at a small, rural hospital. She's an OB-GYN in Northern Idaho, in a place called Sandpoint. And early on, she got called down to the emergency room to examine a woman.
阿米莉亚·亨茨伯格（Amelia Huntsberger）讲过她在一家乡村小医院工作的故事。她是一名妇产科医生，在爱达荷州北部的桑德波因特（Sandpoint）。早些时候，她被叫去急诊室检查一名妇女。
The woman had passed out. She was hemorrhaging a lot of blood. She was miscarrying.
那个妇女昏倒了，正在大量出血，流产了。
I took her to the operating room and I transfused a bunch of blood products. And her labs were starting to be a bit abnormal, and I asked for the lab to get me platelets. The nurse supervisor who was on that night said, oh, well, we don't have those.
我把她送进了手术室，输了很多血液制品。她的实验室指标开始变得有些不正常，我让实验室给我拿血小板。那天晚上值班的护士主管说，噢，我们没有那个。
And I said, oh, we don't have any platelets? Oh, no, we don't have those in the blood bank here. Oh. So she told me that we could get them from Spokane. And I was like, great. Well, let's activate that right away. And she said, oh, OK. Yeah, they come by taxi.
我说，什么？我们没有血小板？噢，不，我们的血库里没有。噢。她告诉我我们可以从斯波坎（Spokane）调过来。我说，太好了。那我们马上联系。她说，噢，好吧。它们是通过出租车运送的。
Like yellow cab taxi?
是那种黄色出租车吗？
Right? And I said, really? Seriously? Blood products are going to be put in a cab and then come to the hospital from Spokane, which is an hour and a half away? And we were in the winter then. She said, yeah, they'll come by cab.
是啊。我说，真的吗？你是认真的吗？血液制品要放在出租车里，然后从一个半小时车程外的斯波坎送到医院？当时还是冬天。她说，是的，它们会坐出租车来。
Most doctors fresh off years of training at fancy urban hospitals might look at an experience like this and want to run from it. But for Amelia, this was her plan, her first choice. She grew up in a place like Sandpoint-- beautiful, rural, surrounded by mountains.
大多数刚从大城市高级医院培训出来、满怀雄心的医生可能遇到这种情况就想逃跑了。但对阿米莉亚来说，这是她的计划，是她的首选。她在像桑德波因特这样的地方长大——美丽、乡村、四周环山。
She did her first delivery in middle school. It was a baby lamb. She used to help her dad out during lambing season. And all through med school she was like, why shouldn't people in rural places get the best care?
她在中学时就接生了第一只小羊。她在接生季节经常帮她父亲的忙。在医学院期间，她总是想，为什么偏远地区的人就不能获得最好的医疗护理？
Amelia is someone who generally takes stuff on if it needs doing. Whenever there's some unpaid committee job no one wants, Amelia signs up. Not in an ego way, it's more like, why wouldn't you do that?
阿米莉亚是个只要有需要，就愿意承担重任的人。每当有那种没人想要的委员会差事，阿米莉亚总是第一个报名。不是为了出风头，更像是，为什么不呢？
Amelia's husband, Vince, he works at the same hospital. He's an ER doctor and he also grew up in a small town. They met in medical school and wanted to settle in a place like this because they knew rural hospitals desperately need doctors. Yes, practicing medicine here in Sandpoint means platelets arrive by taxi. But also, Amelia said, you really get to know your patients. It's nice running into them all over town.
阿米莉亚的丈夫文斯（Vince）也在同一家医院工作。他是一名急诊科医生，也是在小镇长大的。他们在医学院相识，希望在这样的地方定居，因为他们知道乡村医院非常需要医生。是的，在桑德波因特做医生意味着血小板要靠出租车运送。但阿米莉亚说，你也确实能更了解你的病人。在镇上随处碰到他们感觉很温馨。
Half of the day is people that I know, who I'm delighted, like, what are the updates? When's your granddaughter coming home? When somebody comes up to me in the grocery store and wants to ask a question about vaginal discharge, that's not awesome. But when a patient comes up to me and wants to show me her grandchild who I delivered, that's really delightful.
半天时间都在遇到我认识的人，我很高兴，就像，有什么近况？你的孙女什么时候回来？当有人在杂货店走过来问我关于阴道分泌物的问题时，这可不怎么美妙。但当病人走过来向我展示我接生的孩子时，那真是太令人开心了。
Amelia's whole life is in Sandpoint. She and Vince have raised all three of their kids here. Recently, her parents moved here, too. But I've been talking to Amelia for months, over the phone and in person, not because she loves the place, but because she thinks it might be time to leave.
阿米莉亚的生活全都在桑德波因特。她和文斯在这里养育了三个孩子。最近，她的父母也搬到了这里。但我已经和阿米莉亚交谈了几个月，通过电话和面谈，不是因为她热爱这里，而是因为她认为可能是时候离开了。
Amelia did not see herself as an abortion care provider. She's a general OB-GYN, so she sees everyone from teenagers to 90-year-olds. She does pap smears, prenatal care, breast exams, STIs, prescribes birth control, delivers babies. She's got the bulletin board to prove it.
阿米莉亚以前没把自己当成堕胎护理提供者。她是一名普通妇产科医生，所以从青少年到90岁的老人她都看。她做涂片检查、产前护理、乳房检查、检测性传播感染、开避孕药、为孕妇接生。她办公室墙上的布告栏就是证据。
And right now, there are lots of stories about pregnant people dealing with the fall of Roe versus Wade and changes in state laws. But this story is about their doctors. I started calling OB-GYNs when the Supreme Court overturned Roe because I wanted to know what their jobs are like now and how they're changing. And I started hearing about doctors who were thinking of leaving their states because of new laws that criminalize a whole range of common OB-GYN care.
现在，关于孕妇应对“罗诉韦德案”（Roe v. Wade）被推翻和州法律变更的故事有很多。但这个故事是关于她们的医生。最高法院推翻“罗诉韦德案”后，我开始联系妇产科医生，因为我想知道她们现在的工作是什么样，以及正在发生怎样的变化。我开始听到一些医生因为新的州法律——将一系列常见的妇产科护理定为犯罪——而考虑离开她们所在的州。
Idaho is one of those states. It passed some of the most restrictive abortion laws in the country. No exceptions for the health of a pregnant person, no exceptions to save the life of a pregnant person. Here's how state senator, Todd Lakey, one of the sponsors of the bill that would soon become law, talked about what should happen in the case of, for instance, a serious pregnancy complication.
爱达荷州就是其中之一。它通过了全美最严格的一些反堕胎法。其中没有针对孕妇健康的例外，也没有挽救孕妇生命的例外。州参议员托德·莱基（Todd Lakey）是该法案（很快成为法律）的发起人之一，他是这样谈论在发生严重妊娠并发症的情况下该怎么做的。
If the decision was based solely on a question of some type of health, then you're talking about taking the life of the unborn child. So that weighs more heavily than simply health.
如果决定仅基于某种健康问题，那你就是在谈论夺走未出生孩子的生命。所以这比单纯的健康考量要重要得多。
Go ahead.
请继续。
Thank you, Mr. Chairman, and just a follow up. So just, I guess, a yes or no, the health of the woman is irrelevant? Yes or no.
谢谢，主席先生，再追问一句。所以，我猜，这是一个是或否的问题，女性的健康是无关紧要的吗？是或否。
I would say it weighs less, yes, than the life of the child.
我会说它的权重较轻，是的，比起孩子的生命而言。
Lots of people had concerns about the laws. Even the governor, who is anti-abortion, sent a letter to the state senate saying that some parts of these bills would, quote, "In short order, be proven both unconstitutional and unwise." He signed them into law anyway.
很多人对这些法律感到担忧。甚至连反对堕胎的州长都写信给州参议院，称这些法案的部分内容在短时间内就会被证明既违宪又不智。但他还是签署使其生效了。
Idaho's new laws are also some of the most punitive toward doctors. They cover any pregnancy that has a, quote, "fetal heartbeat." Though in the early stages, it's not a heartbeat, in a normal sense-- it's electrical activity in some tissue that will eventually become the heart.
爱达荷州的新法律对医生的惩罚也是最严厉的。它们涵盖了任何有“胎儿心跳”的怀孕情况。虽然在早期，这并不是正常意义上的心跳，而是未来会发育成心脏的某些组织产生的电活动。
The sound you hear with an ultrasound machine? It's created by the machine. But that counts as far as the law is concerned. If a doctor does anything to terminate a pregnancy with a fetal heartbeat, they can be charged with a felony and imprisoned for up to five years, even if, say, they have a patient who is miscarrying, bleeding uncontrollably, and they're trying to save their life.
你在超声波机器上听到的声音？那是机器生成的。但就法律而言，这就算数。如果医生终止了有胎儿心跳的妊娠，他们可能被指控犯有重罪，并被判处最高五年的监禁，即使是在他们面对流产、失血不止的患者，试图挽救其生命时也是如此。
Also, there's this phrase in Idaho's new laws, "affirmative defense." What this means is, in theory, the laws do allow for abortions in the case of rape, incest, or to save the life of a pregnant person. But if a doctor does that, they can be arrested, and have to prove in court with, say a report from the police attesting to rape, or somehow prove that their patient would have died, and a jury would have to agree. Under Idaho's new laws, it's kind of like doctors are assumed guilty, instead of assumed innocent until proven guilty. It doesn't sound legal, but it is.
此外，爱达荷州的新法律中还有个术语叫“肯定性抗辩”（affirmative defense）。这意味着，从理论上讲，这些法律允许在强奸、乱伦或为了挽救孕妇生命的情况下进行堕胎。但如果医生这样做，他们可能会被逮捕，必须在法庭上证明，比如提供警察证明强奸的报告，或者某种程度上证明他们的病人会死，还得让陪审团同意。根据爱达荷州的新法律，医生被假定为有罪，而不是在被证明有罪之前假定无罪。这听起来不合法，但确实如此。
When the abortion ban went into effect, after Roe was overturned, Amelia's first thought was not, we got to leave Sandpoint. She was not at that stage. The stage she was at was, let's fight.
当堕胎禁令在“罗诉韦德案”被推翻后生效时，阿米莉亚的第一反应不是“我们得离开桑德波因特”。她还没到那个阶段。她所处的阶段是：让我们战斗。
If enough doctors speak out, if people understand the reality, they will understand the dangers of these laws and they'll want to change them. Amelia was already on a committee tracking maternal deaths. The state hadn't had one of those, she helped create one.
如果有足够的医生站出来说话，如果人们了解现实，他们就会明白这些法律的危险，并想要改变它们。阿米莉亚已经在关注孕产妇死亡的委员会任职了，该州之前没有这种机构，还是她协助建立的。
She was also heading up the state chapter of the American College of Obstetrics and Gynecologists, ACOG. No one else raised their hand to do it, but Amelia did. So naturally, when a lawsuit was filed against one of the new abortion laws in Idaho, Amelia was part of a coalition trying to change these laws. She knew the lawyers needed testimony from OB-GYNs laying out specific emergency medical care they'd been providing for years, that now, under the new laws, was criminal.
她还是美国妇产科医师协会（ACOG）州分会的主席。没有人愿意做这个，但阿米莉亚做了。因此，很自然地，当针对爱达荷州一项新堕胎法的诉讼提起时，阿米莉亚成为了试图改变这些法律的联盟的一员。她知道律师需要妇产科医生的证词，列出她们多年来一直在提供的紧急医疗护理，而现在根据新法律，这些变成了犯罪。
So I think, OK. Well, I'm going to reach out to as many OB-GYNs as I can think of and have contact information to, and just see if anybody would be willing to make a declaration. And then I kind of realize, I myself have provided care like this.
所以我认为，好吧。我要联系我能想到的尽可能多的妇产科医生，看看是否有人愿意发表声明。然后我意识到，我自己就提供过这样的护理。
So Amelia, who had started out trying to find other OB-GYNs to write about their experiences to help change these new laws, instead started writing about herself, her own medical practice. She'd never thought of herself in the same category as providers of so-called elective abortions, what happens in abortion clinics. She thought of that as a different thing, even though she'd written the word abortion in her patients' medical charts for years.
所以阿米莉亚，最初试图寻找其他妇产科医生来讲述她们的经历以帮助改变这些新法律，现在反而开始写她自己，她自己的医疗实践。她从未把自己归为那些所谓的“选择性堕胎”（ abortion clinics里发生的那种）提供者行列。她认为那是另一回事，尽管多年来她在病人的医疗记录里写过“堕胎”这个词。
The medical term for miscarriages before 20 weeks is spontaneous abortion. About one in five pregnancies end this way, so she treats patients for this all the time. Anti-abortion rhetoric had so effectively separated abortion from health care that, in a way, they'd gotten separated in Amelia's head, too.
20周前流产的医学术语是“自然流产”（spontaneous abortion）。大约五分之一的怀孕以这种方式结束，所以她一直都在为病人治疗。反堕胎言论已经如此有效地将“堕胎”从“医疗护理”中剥离出来，以至于在某种程度上，它们在阿米莉亚的脑海中也被分开了。
Amelia signed her declaration and submitted it. Her written experiences, and those of other OB-GYNs, it all made a difference in the strictness of the law, a small but significant one. The day before the trigger laws in Idaho were about to go into effect, a federal judge agreed to allow emergency abortion procedures that go through actual emergency rooms, for now.
阿米莉亚签署并提交了她的声明。她写下的经历，以及其他妇产科医生的经历，确实对法律的严格程度产生了一点影响，尽管很小但意义重大。就在爱达荷州触发法案即将生效的前一天，一名联邦法官同意允许通过实际急诊室进行的紧急堕胎程序——目前为止。
Did that feel like a big win?
那感觉像是一场大胜利吗？
Yeah, tremendous relief, hopeful. That felt like, OK, somebody is really seeing this with a clear eye and a rational mind, and is like, well, obviously this doesn't make sense.
是的，巨大的宽慰，充满希望。感觉像是，好了，终于有人用清醒的眼光和理性的头脑来看待这件事了，并认为，显而易见，这完全说不通。
Every other part of the laws still went into effect the very next day. And around that time the idea of leaving popped into Amelia's mind for the very first time. She popped it right back out.
法律的所有其他部分在第二天就生效了。就在那个时候，离开的念头第一次出现在阿米莉亚的脑海里。她马上把它排除了。
Hold up. Pause. Let's just see. Let's just see. Let's just see. The circumstances in Idaho are not set in stone. Things are still changing and moving. And so let's see where this goes. Surely this is going to be reined in.
等等。暂停。让我们拭目以待。让我们拭目以待。让我们拭目以待。爱达荷州的情况并非一成不变。事情仍在变化和发展。所以看看事态如何发展。相信这会被遏制的。
This is the same calculation some of the other doctors I've talked to are making-- wait and see. But one of the things they're all waiting and seeing about is, who will be the first OB-GYN put on trial and possibly put in prison for providing health care to one of their patients?
这也是我谈过的其他一些医生所做的计算——等等看。但她们都在等着看的一件事是：谁会成为第一个因向病人提供医疗护理而被起诉，甚至可能被监禁的妇产科医生？
Amelia, back at work, had a whole bunch of new stuff to sort through in her mind with these laws. The new laws defined abortion as the use of any means to intentionally terminate a clinically diagnosable pregnancy. So ectopic pregnancies, for example, came up all the time in her clinic.
阿米莉亚回到工作中，脑子里有许多关于这些法律的新东西需要理清。新法律将“堕胎”定义为使用任何手段故意终止可临床诊断的妊娠。例如，异位妊娠（宫外孕）在她的诊所里经常出现。
An ectopic pregnancy means a fertilized egg is sitting outside of the uterus, and sometimes has what the law calls a fetal heartbeat. It's not viable. It can be fatal. And the longer it sits there, the more danger the patient is in.
异位妊娠意味着受精卵在子宫外，有时还会出现法律所说的“胎儿心跳”。它是无法存活的。它可能是致命的。而且在体内存在的时间越长，病人就越危险。
What am I supposed to do with a patient like this? Per the total abortion ban, I need to wait until she's really sick. I can't act just to protect her health. I should be waiting until I'm saving her life. This is totally opposite of my medical training.
面对这样的病人我该怎么办？按照全面堕胎禁令，我需要等到她病得很重。我不能仅仅为了保护她的健康而采取行动。我应该等到我在抢救她的生命时才能行动。这完全背离了我的医学训练。
Her medical training was, try to stop things before they become life-threatening. The solution used to be straightforward. She'd remove ectopic pregnancies with a quick surgical procedure or inject a drug that would end the pregnancy.
她的医学训练是：在问题危及生命前尝试解决它。解决方法曾经很简单。她会通过快速手术切除异位妊娠，或者注射一种药物来终止妊娠。
One day, Amelia had a patient like that. Their pregnancy test was positive, but Amelia could not find a fertilized egg in their uterus. An injection was clearly the best option. So while the patient was in the exam room, Amelia started calling administrators at her hospital, asking, can I do this? She later talked to some lawyers about what she could do in this kind of situation.
有一天，阿米莉亚遇到了一个这样的病人。她们的妊娠测试是阳性的，但阿米莉亚无法在子宫里找到受精卵。注射显然是最好的选择。所以当病人还在检查室时，阿米莉亚开始给医院的行政人员打电话，问：我可以这样做吗？她后来和一些律师谈过在这种情况下她能做什么。
One answer that I got was that it's probably 90% safe, legally. What does that mean? So you're saying I have a 1-in-10 chance of spending two years in jail with a felony? Is that what you're telling me right now?
我得到的回答是，从法律上讲，大约有90%是安全的。那是什么意思？所以你是说我有十分之一的概率会因为重罪而被关进监狱两年？这就是你现在告诉我的吗？
And 1-in-10 sounds pretty risky.
而且“十分之一”听起来风险相当大。
Right. I got three kids. I mean, what? That's not reassuring to me. It's also not a definite answer. It's like, well-- you know, like that. [HEMS AND HAWS]
对吧。我有三个孩子。我是说，什么？这对我来说并不让人放心。而且这也不是一个肯定的答案。就像是——你知道，像那样。（支支吾吾）
And then, I have another lawyer who I've been in contact with who says, take care of the patient. Do what you've been trained to do. Take care of the patient.
然后，我联系了另一位律师，他说，照顾好病人。做你受训要做的事。照顾好病人。
Amelia advised her patient to go to the ER. The ER-- chaotic, impersonal, and usually more expensive for the patient. But that's the only workaround she had to make sure the patient got the care they needed while protecting herself under these new laws. Amelia started sending all of her ectopic pregnancies to the ER.
阿米莉亚建议她的病人去急诊室。急诊室——混乱、没人情味，而且对病人来说通常更贵。但那是她唯一能确保病人得到所需护理，同时根据这些新法律保护自己的变通办法。阿米莉亚开始把所有的异位妊娠案例都转送急诊室。
Here's another thing Amelia realized about the way the laws are set up. Even though ER doctors in Idaho should theoretically be protected from criminal prosecutions, a prosecutor could still decide to try and charge her husband Vince anyways. And under the law as it stands, people can definitely sue doctors, including ER doctors, for damages. So it was dawning on Amelia that it was possible that she and Vince could both now be sued by multiple family members of a quote, "preborn child."
关于这些法律的设定方式，阿米莉亚还意识到了另一件事。尽管爱达荷州的急诊医生理论上应该受到保护免于刑事起诉，但检察官仍然可以决定尝试起诉她的丈夫文斯。而且按照现行法律，人们肯定可以起诉医生，包括急诊医生，要求损害赔偿。所以阿米莉亚开始意识到，她和文斯现在有可能都被所谓的“未出生儿童”的多位家庭成员起诉。
The father of the preborn child, a grandparent of the preborn child, a sibling of the preborn child, or an aunt or uncle of the preborn child. So when I read this, does this mean that the father of a rapist, that the sister of a rapist, that the brother of the rapist can sue the physician? It absolutely does.
未出生孩子的父亲、未出生孩子的祖父母、未出生孩子的兄弟姐妹，或未出生孩子的叔叔阿姨。所以当我读到这里，这是不是意味着强奸犯的父亲、强奸犯的姐妹、强奸犯的兄弟可以起诉医生？绝对是这样。
Family members can each file individual separate lawsuits asking for a minimum of $20,000. And they have up to four years to file a lawsuit.
每个家庭成员都可以分别提起诉讼，要求至少2万美元的赔偿。而且他们有长达四年的时间来提起诉讼。
All right, back to the language of the law, statutory damages in an amount not less than $20,000. So just take note, instead of having, here's the ceiling, this is the maximum, we start with a minimum payout.
好了，回到法律的用词，“不低于2万美元的法定赔偿”。所以注意了，不是“这是上限，这是最高限额”，我们一开始就是赔偿金下限。
So all of that was on Amelia's mind when another patient came into the clinic. She had an ectopic pregnancy that ruptured. Amelia put a camera into her patient's abdomen.
所以当另一个病人来到诊所时，所有这些都在阿米莉亚的脑海里。她有异位妊娠破裂。阿米莉亚把摄像机探入了病人的腹部。
And I'm like, oh, my gosh. There is way more blood than there was described on the ultrasound that this person had 60 minutes ago. We have got to move quickly.
我说，噢，天哪。这里面的血比这个人在60分钟前做超声波时描述的要多得多。我们必须迅速采取行动。
The bleeding could kill her. And the way to stop the bleeding was to abort the pregnancy, which was never going to be viable anyway.
出血可能会杀了她。而止血的方法就是终止妊娠，反正那也是永远无法存活的。
When you do surgery like that, where it's an emergency and somebody's having ongoing, active bleeding, that's already high stress. And that sort of high stress, I trained for that. I know what to do with that. I can handle that.
当你进行那种紧急手术，有人正在持续活跃出血时，压力已经非常高了。对于那种高压，我受过训练。我知道该怎么做。我可以应付。
Then, you add in this other weird layer of, is her brother going to not understand that this was a not-viable pregnancy and that her life was at risk? And what about her mom? What about her partner? What about her sister?
然后，加上这种奇怪的层面：她的兄弟会不会不理解这是一次无法存活的妊娠，而她的生命处于危险之中？她妈妈呢？她伴侣呢？她姐妹呢？
Do these people understand how serious this condition is, or do they only understand that I removed a pregnancy that had a heartbeat? I don't know. How am I supposed to know?
这些人理解病情的严重性吗？还是说他们只知道我终止了一个有心跳的妊娠？我不知道。我该怎么知道？
She started looking at her patients' charts as evidence she might need in court. She wrote down words like, life-threatening, and high chance of mortality for some theoretical future lawsuit.
她开始把病人的病历看作她在法庭上可能需要的证据。她写下了“危及生命”和“死亡风险高”之类的词，为未来理论上的诉讼做准备。
Another case, a patient came in to see her for a biopsy of the lining of their uterus. Amelia found herself worrying, wait, what if she's pregnant? The person had mentioned they hadn't been using contraception.
另一个案例，一个病人来看她进行子宫内膜活检。阿米莉亚开始担心，等等，如果她怀孕了怎么办？这个人提到她一直没采取避孕措施。
And so then I'm thinking, well, wait a minute. When was her last menstrual period? We're definitely doing a urine pregnancy test, but what's the plausibility that there could be a pregnancy that isn't detectable yet, super, super early stages?
所以我心想，等等。她上次月经是什么时候？我们绝对要做尿液妊娠测试，但有没有可能存在那种还检测不出来的怀孕情况，处于超早期阶段？
In these early stages, a P-Test is not definitive. It can still come up as negative.
在早期阶段，P测试不是决定性的。它可能依然显示阴性。
If I had a quarter for every single time that somebody said, there's no way I'm pregnant and then has a positive pregnancy test, then I'd be rich.
如果有人说“我绝对不可能怀孕”，然后妊娠测试却呈阳性，那我每遇到一次就赚一个季度，我现在就发财了。
If there was any chance that this patient was pregnant, a biopsy could inadvertently terminate this patient's potential pregnancy.
如果这个病人有任何怀孕的可能，活检可能会无意中终止这个病人的潜在怀孕。
So there's part of me that's like, we should not do anything today. She needs to use effective contraception for a month and then come back, and then I can do this procedure once I'm really sure that she's not pregnant. But that's also really impractical for this person who's driven hours to come see me.
所以有一部分我在想，我们今天什么都不应该做。她需要有效地避孕一个月，然后再回来，一旦我确定她没怀孕，我就可以进行这个手术。但这对于这个开了几个小时车来看我的人来说太不切实际了。
And further, she has a medical problem that needs attention. She's already waited to see me. This visit has nothing to do with pregnancy.
而且，她有一个需要关注的医疗问题。她已经等了很久才见到我。这次访问与怀孕无关。
Amelia didn't send her back. She treated her. This is what it means for Amelia to have these laws in her head all the time, to have to think of every single person who enters her office as pregnant or possibly pregnant, to have that become her constant focus.
阿米莉亚没有让她回去。她治疗了她。这就是阿米莉亚一直被这些法律困扰的意义所在：她必须把每一个进入她办公室的人都视为怀孕或可能怀孕的人，这成了她持续关注的重点。
More and more, she's finding that what she believes is good care, the kind she's obliged to provide under medical malpractice laws, is in direct conflict with what the new laws say. And she knows these laws are in her patients' minds, too, because they're asking her, will I get in trouble for this or that? Is this legal-- worrying about that on top of whatever actual medical problem they came to her for. In other states, there have already been numerous reports about doctors delaying care for pregnant patients, or even turning them away because of new laws criminalizing OB-GYN care. Some patients have almost died and ended up in the ICU.
她越来越发现，她认为好的医疗护理——她根据医疗事故法有义务提供的护理——与新法律的规定直接冲突。而且她知道这些法律也在病人的脑海里，因为她们在问她：这会不会让我惹上麻烦？这合法吗？——除了她们本来要看的医疗问题外，还要担心这个。在其他州，已经有大量关于医生推迟对孕妇进行护理，甚至因为将妇产科护理定为犯罪的新法律而拒绝病人的报告。一些病人差点死亡，并住进了ICU。
Amelia and her husband for months were pinning their hopes on Idaho's Supreme Court overturning the state's abortion laws. That was their big wait and see, while in the back of her mind, there was this growing, nagging feeling. Will we be able to keep living here if the court's decision doesn't go our way?
几个月来，阿米莉亚和她的丈夫一直寄希望于爱达荷州最高法院推翻该州的堕胎法。那是她们等待的一大关键，而在她的心底深处，有一种不断滋长的恼人感觉：如果法院的裁决没有按我们的意愿发展，我们还能继续住在这里吗？
I'm just so agitated as I am describing all of this. And the intensity level is just so high for me. And my friend says, well, so when do you just put this all down and just take a break?
我在描述这一切的时候感到非常焦虑。对我来说，那种强度非常高。我的朋友说，好吧，那你什么时候能放下这一切，休息一下？
And I'm thinking, what does she mean? Take a break? How can I take a break? I'm literally vibrating out of my body. I mean, that's also a problem, that inability to escape this. I don't know how to put it down, just sort of this, walking around, whether at work or at home, and just these deep sighs, just feeling-- [SIGHS] like there, see? I do it without even thinking about it.
我在想，她是什么意思？休息一下？我怎么能休息？我简直是在灵魂震颤。那是另一个问题，那种无法逃避这种压力的状态。我不知道如何放下它，只是那种——到处走动，无论是在工作还是在家，只会发出沉重的叹息，感觉——（叹息）就像那样，看吧？我没意识到就叹出来了。
She was having trouble sleeping-- a first for her.
她开始失眠了——这对她来说还是第一次。
Laying awake at night and thinking about this or that, and I think just the tension that you're holding in your body or having to think about taking a deep breath because you've been holding your breath all day.
晚上躺在床上睡不着，想着这个或那个。我想只是因为你身体里积压的紧张感，或者不得不提醒自己深呼吸，因为你一整天都屏着呼吸。
Amelia and Vince have had some wild conversations in the last few months. They have talked about the possibility that both of them could end up in jail, or face multiple lawsuits with potentially massive civil penalties, or lose their medical licenses. Chances are probably small, but also, it's impossible to be sure.
阿米莉亚和文斯在过去几个月里进行了一些疯狂的谈话。她们讨论过两人最终都可能入狱的可能性，或者面临多项可能产生巨大民事处罚的诉讼，或者失去行医执照。这种可能性也许很小，但也无法确定。
What happens if both of us are in jail for two years? Who is raising our kids? We know, yeah, we have a plan for our kids if that happened.
如果我们要入狱两年，谁来抚养我们的孩子？我们知道，是的，如果发生了这种情况，我们有针对孩子的计划。
What is your plan?
你们的计划是什么？
Family.
家庭。
She didn't want to say more about who exactly their kids-- 11, 8, and 6 years old-- would go to. It was the first time I'd seen her look physically uncomfortable answering a question. She kind of pursed her lips and shook her head no. She just couldn't go there.
她不想再说到底要把孩子——11岁、8岁和6岁——交给谁。这是我第一次看到她在回答问题时表现出身体上的不适。她抿了抿嘴，摇了摇头。她实在无法面对。
A couple months ago, a few things happened that moved the idea of leaving from the back of Amelia's mind to the front. The first took place in a car parked outside the state capital in Boise.
几个月前，发生了几件事，让离开的念头从阿米莉亚脑海的深处移到了前面。第一件事发生在一辆停在博伊西州议会大厦外的车里。
She was with another OB-GYN. They'd been talking to the people in the governor's office about expanding Medicaid coverage for people who'd just given birth. So they were sitting in Amelia's rental car and her friend turned to her.
她和另一位妇产科医生在一起。她们一直在和州长办公室的人谈论扩大医疗补助（Medicaid），惠及刚分娩的民众。所以她们坐在阿米莉亚的租赁车里，她的朋友转向她。
And she had told me at that point that she was deciding between different job options.
在那一点上，她告诉我她正在权衡不同的工作选择。
Job options in another state. This was a huge blow to Amelia. She'd been a key ally in this fight. Then, right after that conversation, Amelia caught up with another friend, a lawyer who'd also been fighting these laws. Amelia remembers her saying--
在另一个州的工作选择。这对阿米莉亚是个巨大的打击。她是这场战斗中的关键盟友。然后，在这次谈话后，阿米莉亚赶上了另一位朋友，一位也一直在反对这些法律的律师。阿米莉亚记得她当时说——
I haven't told many people this yet, but I'm planning to leave. So in the same day, in Boise, these two people who I respect, and admire, and trust told me, this state is not a place for me anymore. And I'm planning my exit.
我还没告诉很多人，但我计划离开。所以在同一天，在博伊西，这两个我尊重、钦佩和信任的人告诉我：这个州不再适合我了。我正在计划离开。
And then, the state Supreme Court ruling she and her husband Vince had been waiting for came down. Amelia was at home and on her day off when it happened.
然后，她和丈夫文斯一直等待的州最高法院裁决下来了。阿米莉亚那天没上班，正在家里。
I happened to look at my email and there was this message from one of the lawyers that just said in the subject line, Supreme Court decision out, not good, will follow up later. And I just kind of was panicked of, what does this mean?
我恰好看了一眼电子邮件，有一条律师发的消息，主题行写着：“最高法院裁决出炉，不太好，稍后跟进。”我当时就慌了，这意味着什么？
And so then, I'm trying to do this Google search. Nothing comes up. And so then I'm like, well, I've got to go. I've got to pick up my kids. So I get in my car and I drive to school pickup, and then I'm waiting in line and the car's in park.
所以我试图去谷歌搜索。什么也没出来。我心想，好吧，我得走了。我得去接孩子。所以我上车开车去学校，排队等候时把车挂在停车档。
Then, I pull out my emails again to just try to see, can I find anything about this? And then other people are linking to a summary, and this and that. And I'm sobbing, right? I was just like, the Supreme Court in Idaho believes that all three abortion laws are constitutional.
然后，我再次掏出邮件想看看能不能找到关于这件事的任何信息。然后其他人链接到了一个总结，这之类的。我在抽泣，对吧？我当时就在想，爱达荷州最高法院认为所有三项堕胎法都是宪法规定的。
The court carved out one small exception-- ectopic pregnancies, but not miscarriages, not deadly fetal anomalies, or anything else. Amelia broke the news to Vince. She says the first question he asked her was--
法院只开了一个小小的例外——异位妊娠，但没有包括流产，没有包括致命的胎儿异常，也没有其他任何情况。阿米莉亚把这个消息告诉了文斯。她说他问她的第一个问题是——
Is this it? Is this the tipping point, was his question to me. Is this a place that we can continue to live, and practice medicine, and raise our family?
这是最终结果吗？这是转折点吗？这是他的问题。这是一个我们能继续生活、继续行医、继续抚养家庭的地方吗？
What did you say?
你说了什么？
Yeah, I think I'm not at the tipping point yet. And I asked back to him, are you? Is this the nail in the coffin for you? Are you done? And we're not there yet, right? We're not at the tipping point yet.
是的，我想我还没到那个转折点。我反问他，你到了吗？这是你心里的最后一根稻草吗？你受够了吗？我们还没到那一步，对吧？我们还没到那个转折点。
Do you know what your tipping point is?
你知道你的转折点是什么吗？
No. I'm not-- I'm not sure. Obviously this Supreme Court decision is a big blow, and I don't know exactly where that line is of what I can tolerate.
不知道。我——我不确定。显然，最高法院的这个决定是一个沉重的打击，我不知道我能容忍的底线到底在哪里。
Vince's job in the ER still had some protection. That federal court ruling still holds for now, allowing emergency abortion procedures that go through actual emergency rooms. But everything felt precarious.
文斯在急诊室的工作目前还有些保护。联邦法院的那个裁决目前依然有效，允许通过实际急诊室进行紧急堕胎程序。但一切都感觉岌岌可危。
Amelia and Vince now talk about leaving almost every day. Sometimes leaving can be an act of protest, but Amelia feels like it would be a retreat, a giving in, like, I can save myself but I'd be leaving my patients behind. She's worried that if she left, her clinic could collapse.
阿米莉亚和文斯现在几乎每天都在讨论离开。有时离开可以是一种抗议行为，但阿米莉亚感觉那会是一种撤退，一种屈服，就像，“我可以拯救自己，但我把我的病人抛在了后面。”她担心如果她走了，她的诊所可能会倒闭。
She's one of only four OB-GYNs, and one of the others is thinking about leaving, too. Amelia says, if they did leave first, she'd probably have to leave, too. If Amelia or one of her colleagues does leave Sandpoint, the options for finding a replacement are bleak. The last time an OB-GYN left her clinic, it took them two years to find another one, and that was before Roe fell. Idaho already has a severe shortage of doctors, one of the worst in the country.
她是仅有的四名妇产科医生之一，其中另一名也在考虑离开。阿米莉亚说，如果她们先走了，她可能也不得不走。如果阿米莉亚或她的同事中有人离开桑德波因特，寻找替代者的选择就很渺茫。上次有一位妇产科医生离开她的诊所时，她们花了两年时间才找到下一个，而且那还是在“罗诉韦德案”被推翻之前。爱达荷州已经出现了严重的医生短缺，是全美最严重的州之一。
I was looking at social media and somebody was talking about a person who is completing their OB-GYN residency and was looking to come to the Pacific Northwest. And there was all this, hey, we've got an opening in Washington. We've got an opening in Oregon. We've got openings in Montana.
我在看社交媒体，有人在谈论一个刚刚完成妇产科住院医师培训的人，正打算去太平洋西北地区。然后到处都在说：“嘿，华盛顿州有空缺。俄勒冈州有空缺。蒙大拿州有空缺。”
And I'm like, hey, there's all sorts of openings in Idaho. And then I'm laughing out loud because I'm like, who is going to be finishing their residency training and being like, I definitely want to go to the state with the super strict abortion laws that criminalize health care? I literally laughed out loud, and that's awful, right?
我心想，嘿，爱达荷州有各种空缺。然后我大笑起来，因为我心想，谁会完成住院医师培训后说：“我绝对想去那个有超严格堕胎法、将医疗护理定为犯罪的州？”我真的大笑出来，这太糟糕了，对吧？
I'm laughing about how ridiculous it is that somebody would choose to come and practice medicine here. That's terrible. That should be very alarming to anyone. But I didn't-- I was like, it's like, you laugh so you don't cry. I don't even know. Yeah.
我笑着看一个人选择来这里行医是多么荒谬。这太可怕了。这应该引起任何人的极大警觉。但我没——我当时想，这就像是，笑着才不会哭。我甚至不知道。是啊。
Did you post, there's tons of openings in Idaho, or did you know better?
你是发了“爱达荷州有大量空缺”，还是你心里有数？
I sure did. And I was like, I mean, but then you have to deal with the laws here. But I'm like, legit, if you're willing to deal with the laws, I will hook you up.
我确实发了。我的意思是，但你得处理这里的法律。但我说，诚心说，如果你愿意处理这些法律，我会帮你联系的。
I know all the people who are looking. I got you. But you're not going to want to come here. Are you kidding me? I know that. I mean, if you do want to come here, cool. Like I say, I'll help you.
我认识所有正在寻找的人。我有门路。但你不会想来这里的。你在开玩笑吗？我知道这一点。我的意思是，如果你确实想来这里，太酷了。就像我说的，我会帮你的。
If 1 is, never leave, and 10 is, we got to go, where are you on that spectrum right now?
如果1代表“绝不离开”，10代表“必须走”，你现在在这个光谱上的哪个位置？
I don't know how to answer that.
我不知道怎么回答。
What makes it hard?
是什么让你感到困难？
[SIGHS] I don't want to leave here. And just turning it into something more black and white like a number scale does-- feels hard. I don't want to leave, but I don't know if I can stay.
（叹息）我不想离开这里。仅仅把它变成一种像数字量表那样的非黑即白的东西——感觉很难。我不想离开，但我不知道我还能不能留下。
Some doctors have decided to leave. I talked to two OB-GYNs-- one had just left Texas, the other, Tennessee. Their jobs are different from Amelia's because they're high-risk OBs, and so they're seeing some of the most difficult cases.
有些医生决定离开了。我和两位妇产科医生谈过——一个刚从德克萨斯州离开，另一个从田纳西州。她们的工作和阿米莉亚不同，因为她们是高危产科医生，所以她们看的是一些最困难的病例。
They told me they were just like Amelia when new abortion laws went into effect in their states. They also wanted to stay. And they also didn't know what their tipping point was and wanted to keep treating their patients.
她们告诉我，在新堕胎法在她们州生效时，她们就像阿米莉亚一样。她们也想留下。她们也不知道自己的转折点是什么，也想继续治疗她们的病人。
And each of them described the same kind of moment to me. One day, they found themselves in a terrible situation with a patient, brought on by trying to comply with the new laws. One of them had to send a patient to another state in an ambulance. It was a five-hour ride. The patient's blood pressure was rising, and by the time she got to a hospital, her kidneys were starting to fail.
每个人都向我描述了同样的那种时刻。有一天，她们发现自己因试图遵守新法律而让病人陷入了可怕的境地。其中一个不得不把病人用救护车送到另一个州。那是五小时的车程。病人的血压在升高，当她到达医院时，她的肾脏已经开始衰竭。
The other doctor had to turn away a patient pregnant with twins. One of the twins was going to die and the doctor needed to intervene to save the other's life, but he couldn't because of the laws. He doesn't know what happened to the patient, but he knew, I need to leave.
另一位医生不得不拒绝了一个怀着双胞胎的病人。其中一个双胞胎即将死亡，医生需要介入以挽救另一个的生命，但他因为法律原因无法这样做。他不知道那个病人后来怎么样了，但他知道，“我得离开。”
Miki Meek, she's one of the producers of our show. Coming up, is there a statute of limitations on telling a friend, I thought you were way off base? We'll find out together. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
米基·米克，她是本节目的制作人之一。接下里，对于告诉朋友“我觉得你完全错了”，是否有诉讼时效？我们将一探究竟。稍后继续，来自芝加哥公共广播电台，我们的节目将继续进行。
It's This American Life. I'm Nancy Updike, sitting in for Ira Glass. Today's show, "When To Leave," or if.
这里是《美国生活》。我是南希·厄普代克，代班艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目主题，“何时离开”，或者说，是否离开。
We're at Act Two of two. Act Two, The Leaving Expert. The whole idea for this show came from me reading a story by Masha Gessen, a New Yorker story, Masha is a staff writer there. Reports a lot on Russia, among many other subjects.
这是两幕节目中的第二幕。第二幕，离开专家。本期节目的整个构思来源于我阅读马沙·格森（Masha Gessen）的一篇文章，《纽约客》的一篇报道，马沙是那里的专职作家。报道了很多关于俄罗斯的课题。
Masha grew up in the Soviet Union then moved to the United States as a teenager and lives here now. The New Yorker story was all about leaving, about Russians leaving Russia. Masha was just about to board a plane to Russia when Russia invaded Ukraine a year ago. And almost immediately after landing, Masha started hearing from people, from friends, about leaving.
马沙在苏联长大，十几岁时移居美国，现在住在这里。《纽约客》的文章全是关于离开，关于俄罗斯人离开俄罗斯。一年前，在俄罗斯入侵乌克兰时，马沙正准备登机去俄罗斯。落地后几乎立刻，马沙就开始收到人们，收到朋友关于离开的消息。
I'm trying to think who the first person was. I think it was actually Vera, my closest friend. And I think the conversation was, sort of, we're thinking of leaving. We're thinking of getting tickets to Georgia. Vera has family in Georgia.
我在想第一个人是谁。我想其实是维拉（Vera），我最好的朋友。我想当时对话的意思是，“我们在考虑离开。我们在考虑买去格鲁吉亚的票。”维拉在格鲁吉亚有亲戚。
Do you think we should go now, or in a couple of months when our 16-year-old gets her foreign travel passports? Was it still going to be viable to leave in a couple of months? Were they going to close the borders? But it still felt almost abstract. And then, a couple of days later, she said, we're leaving Wednesday.
你觉得我们应该现在走，还是等几个月等我们16岁的孩子拿到外国旅行护照再走？几个月后离开还可行吗？他们会关闭边境吗？但那时感觉还很抽象。然后，几天后，她说：“我们要周三离开。”
And then, while Masha was at Vera's place for their goodbye gathering--
然后，当马沙在维拉家参加她们的告别聚会时——
Another mutual friend of ours came by and he was sort of saying, why do you feel you have to leave? What's the big deal? There's always time.
我们另一个共同朋友来了，他当时就像是说：“为什么你觉得非走不可？有什么大不了的？时间总会有的。”
Not an unreasonable question, Masha thought at the time. That night, overnight, more leaving. Masha went to the last independent television station in Russia, TV Rain, and saw a whole scene unfolding. Staffers at the station had gotten word that the prosecutor's office was investigating TV Rain for quote, "extremism," which meant any one of them could go to jail for years.
马沙当时认为这并非不合理的问题。那天晚上，一夜之间，更多人选择了离开。马沙去了俄罗斯最后一家独立电视台，“雨”电视台（TV Rain），看到了整个场景的展开。电视台工作人员得到消息，检察官办公室正在以“极端主义”为由调查“雨”电视台，这意味着他们中的任何一个人都可能入狱多年。
Staffers also heard that special forces were coming to search the studios. Other media outlets had been searched before and people had been roughed up. So staff members who were at the station--
工作人员还听说特种部队要来搜查演播室。其他媒体机构之前被搜查过，人们被粗暴对待过。所以身在电视台的工作人员——
Ran out of the building, sort of huddled in a pub outside, trying to book tickets on their cell phones. So there was this sort of call and response where people would be like, Bishkek, two tickets. I'm grabbing those.
从大楼里跑出来，蜷缩在外面的酒吧里，试图在手机上订票。所以当时出现了一种呼应，人们会喊：“比什凯克，两张票。我抢到了。”
Right, like an auction. Yeah, yeah, do I hear--
对，就像拍卖一样。对，对，我听到——
It wasn't even an auction. It's hard to--
那甚至不是拍卖。很难去——
I know they weren't auctioning them off, but the sort of publicness of it.
我知道他们不是在拍卖，但那种公共性。
Yeah, and a sense of rush, and just very adrenaline-y, and very desperate.
是的，一种匆忙感，非常肾上腺素飙升，非常绝望。
And then, the next day, I went to visit other friends. And I walked in and I realized, oh, this is their goodbye party.
然后，第二天，我去拜访其他朋友。走进去我才意识到，噢，这是她们的告别派对。
Oh, my god.
噢，天哪。
And so the friend from the night before, the one who had been asking, what's the point, was also there. And he said, I'm leaving tomorrow. And that was just like, he looked like he was shell shocked. Because I think something had changed inside him that--
所以前一天晚上的那个朋友，那个问“有什么意义”的人，也在那里。他说：“我明天要走。”他看起来像遭受了冲击。因为我想他内心某种东西变了——
From one day to the next?
从一天到第二天？
From one day to the next. And he wasn't even-- he couldn't process what had changed. He knew it had changed and he knew he was leaving, and he was shocked by what he was doing.
从一天到第二天。而且他甚至——他无法处理发生了什么改变。他知道变了，他知道他要走了，他对自己正在做的事情感到震惊。
Within a week, all of Masha's friends had left Russia, all of them.
一周内，马沙所有的朋友都离开了俄罗斯，全部。
And I don't want to say that they're running for their lives, which is another very important aspect of this whole immigration is, because people are acutely aware that they're not running for their lives, that there are, in fact, other people who were running for their lives at that very same time.
我不想说她们是在逃命，这是整个移民的另一个非常重要的方面，因为人们敏锐地意识到她们不是在逃命，实际上在同一时间有其他人正在逃命。
In Ukraine.
在乌克兰。
Because of the same war, right?
因为同一场战争，对吧？
Yeah.
是的。
But that they're running to salvage their sense of selves and to be able to be in the world.
但她们是为了挽救自我意识，能够活在这个世界上而奔走。
It's hard to gauge how many Russians have left the country in the last year. Tens of thousands, hundreds of thousands? It's a lot, whatever it is. People have left for all sorts of reasons. One reason? New laws.
很难估算去年有多少俄罗斯人离开了这个国家。数以万计，数以十万计？无论多少，都非常多。人们离开的原因各不相同。一个原因是什么？新法律。
There were a couple of different laws that they passed a week after the full-scale invasion began, one that made it punishable to call the war a war, and another was that made it a crime to discredit the armed forces of Russia.
全方位入侵开始一周后，他们通过了几项不同的法律，一项是将称战争为“战争”定为应受惩罚的行为，另一项是将贬低俄罗斯武装部队定为犯罪。
And that's one of those wide-angle laws that you can do that without realizing that's what you're doing if somebody really wants to--
那是那种广角法律，如果你不意识到这就是你正在做的，如果有人真的想——
That's exactly--
那正是——
--make the case.
——制造案例。
--right. So in a way, it's a more insidious law than-- because calling a war a war, you know what you're supposed to do. You know what you're not supposed to do. But, of course, terror works much more effectively through laws that are vague and that can't possibly be uniformly applied.
——对的。所以在某种程度上，它比——因为称战争为战争，你知道你该做什么。你知道你不该做什么。但是，当然，恐怖通过模糊且无法统一适用的法律来运作更为有效。
There's another reason I wanted to talk to Masha in particular about leaving. Masha is a bit of a leaving expert, like I said, not just as a reporter but in their own life. Masha has moved countries three times, each time with no idea if they would ever live there again.
我想和马沙专门讨论离开的另一个原因。正如我所说，马沙是一位“离开专家”，不仅作为记者，在生活中也是。马沙搬了三次国家，每次都不知道是否会再回去。
The first time was when Masha was 14 years old and the whole family left the Soviet Union to come to America. Then, Masha moved back to Russia in the '90s. They went in 1991 on a reporting assignment.
第一次是在马沙14岁时，全家离开苏联来到美国。然后，马沙在90年代搬回了俄罗斯。她们在1991年因为一个报道任务去了那里。
The Soviet Union was in the final stages of unmaking itself. And what was left was the most exciting place on Earth to Masha. It was Russia remaking itself. Masha also felt something unexpected there, they felt at home, a profound experience after so long away.
苏联正处于解体的最后阶段。留下来的是马沙眼中地球上最令人兴奋的地方。那是俄罗斯在重塑自我。马沙在那里还感受到了意想不到的东西：她们感受到了归属感，在离家这么久之后这是一次深刻的体验。
Masha spent the next 22 years living there, loved it, never wanted to leave. And then, Masha did leave Russia and moved back here. Seeing their friends leave now reminded Masha of just how hard that decision had been, to know when to leave. It was also about new laws.
马沙在那里生活了22年，热爱那里，从没想过要离开。然后，马沙确实离开了俄罗斯，搬回了这里。看着朋友们现在离开提醒了马沙，那个决定是多么困难，知道何时离开。这也与新法律有关。
Even when they were considering the first law against so-called LGBT propaganda to minors, it seemed so absurd.
即便在她们考虑第一项针对所谓的LGBT未成年人宣传的法律时，它也显得那么荒谬。
This was back in 2012.
那是2012年的事。
And I was like, I was supposed to testify. This was still at a time when one-- someone like me-- might go and testify in the Human Rights Council. And then the person who was organizing the hearings said, yeah, there's no way they're going to pass it. We're not going to hold a hearing. Let's not draw more attention to it.
我当时本该去作证。那仍然是在一个人——像我这样的人——可能会去人权理事会作证的时期。然后组织听证会的人说：“是啊，他们不可能通过的。我们不举行听证会。不要引起更多注意。”
And then, of course, they passed it. And the Parliament started talking about removing children from families. And I went to protest and got beaten up. And it's not like it was news, but I'd never actually been beaten up before.
然后，当然，他们通过了。议会开始谈论把孩子从家庭中带走。我去抗议，被打了一顿。这算不上什么新闻，但我从未真正挨过揍。
Do you think you were targeted specifically?
你认为你是被专门针对的吗？
Yes, I was definitely targeted specifically, in broad daylight, with the police looking on. It's a profound experience, even if you know that sort of thing happens to other people, even people you know. And then, they passed a law banning adoption by people who are in same-sex relationships or have citizenships of countries where same-sex marriage is legal. And my oldest son is adopted, so then it was just like, we have to leave.
是的，我绝对是被专门针对的，在大白天，在警察的注视下。这是一次深刻的体验，即使你知道那种事情会发生在其他人身上，甚至是你认识的人。然后，他们通过了一项禁止同性关系或有同性婚姻合法国家国籍的人收养的法律。我最大的儿子是被收养的，所以那时候就觉得：我们必须离开。
That now describes you and your family so specifically.
这现在描述你和你的家庭太具体了。
Exactly. So we put my oldest son on a plane, and then--
正是如此。所以我们把我最大的儿子送上飞机，然后——
How old was he?
他多大？
He was 14.
他14岁。
14 is the same age Masha was when the family left the Soviet Union, a whole cycle of leaving and leaving again. Masha told me that, in the mix of feelings they've had in the last year, seeing and talking to friends who've left Russia is a strange kind of relief.
14岁正是马沙离开苏联时的年龄，这是一场完整的离开又离开的循环。马沙告诉我，在过去一年里，当她们看到并与离开俄罗斯的朋友交谈时，这是一种奇怪的宽慰。
In a way, the world has become mentally more-- it makes more sense.
在某种程度上，世界变得在心理上更——它更有意义了。
To you?
对你而言？
To me and to us as a group that we're on the same side of not only the mental border but the physical border.
对我而言，也对我们这个群体而言，我们在心理边界和物理边界的同一侧。
For years after Masha left, while friends stayed, Masha sometimes wondered, worried, did I make the right call by leaving? Could I have stayed, too?
马沙离开后的多年里，朋友们留了下来，马沙有时会纳闷、担忧：我离开的决定对吗？我本来也能留下吗？
There was a nagging thought of, well, maybe it was possible to live there. And so maybe I overreacted. Maybe I was hysterical about Putin. He's terrible, but how terrible is he?
曾有一个挥之不去的念头：“嗯，也许在那里生活是有可能的。所以我可能反应过度了。我可能对普京歇斯底里了。他很糟糕，但他到底有多糟糕？”
And now, a lot of that is just-- that's just gone. He is as terrible as anyone has ever been. I was definitely not hysterical. And no, it wasn't actually possible to have a life there.
现在，这些想法大部分都——都没了。他就像任何人曾经展现的那样糟糕。我绝对没有歇斯底里。而且不，在那里确实不可能过上那种生活。
And are people saying that to you? Is anyone saying to you, I thought actually you were a little off the deep end and now I see what you mean, or something?
有人这么对你说吗？有没有人对你说：“我觉得你其实有点走火入魔，现在我明白了你的意思”，之类的？
Yeah. Yeah, people have said that. And it's funny because I even heard it from people who didn't actually say to me, you're crazy, years ago, but now have said, OK, I thought you were a little-- maybe overreacting a little, but I was wrong.
是的。是的，人们这么对我说过。很有趣，因为我甚至从那些几年前并没有对我说“你疯了”的人那里听到过，但现在却说：“好吧，我想你有点——也许反应过度了，但我错了。”
These conversations just seem so strange to me, to have somebody say that and to-- I don't know. It seems so sad. It's like, oh, yeah. I kind of wish you were right, I wish I had overreacted.
这些对话对我来说太奇怪了，有人这么说，然后——我不知道。这看起来太悲伤了。就像是：“噢，是啊。我倒希望你是对的，我倒希望我反应过度了。”
Exactly. And I mean, that was always my go-to phrase, like, I'll be really happy if you prove me wrong.
正是。我的意思是，那一直是我惯用的口头禅：“如果你证明我错了，我会非常高兴。”
Yeah. Yeah.
是啊。是啊。
If I'm being emotionally honest about it--
如果我在情感上诚实的话——
Yes, please.
是的，请讲。
--of course, I don't wish that I'd overreacted because the amount of regret I'd have if I'd overreacted would be unmanageable. So it's not like I'm full of schadenfreude for having told you so. But, yeah, there's an odd sort of emotional peace with having things fall into place.
——当然，我不希望我反应过度，因为如果我反应过度，我会有的遗憾将是无法承受的。所以并不是说因为我早说了，我就充满了幸灾乐祸。但是，是的，当事情各就各位时，有一种奇怪的情感平静。
I asked Masha if they ever think about leaving this country. Masha had a few different answers to that. My brain bookmarked this one.
我问马沙她们是否考虑过离开这个国家。马沙有几个不同的答案。我的大脑记下了这个：
Dissidents, Soviet dissidents were great for setting down rules to live by. And I think one of their rules was, you're useless in prison or dead. But as long as you're not in prison or dead, and you're not facing a significant risk of going to prison or being dead, make a difference where you are. I think that's a pretty-- this country is so far from our losing the ability to make a difference.
持不同政见者，苏联的持不同政见者，他们为生活准则设定规则很在行。我认为他们的准则之一是：“你在监狱里或死的时候是没用的。”但只要你没在监狱里也没死，并且没有面临入狱或死亡的重大风险，在你所在的地方做出改变。我想这是一个相当——这个国家离我们失去做出改变的能力还很远。
Yeah. Yeah. I guess I wonder if you have an eye on laws changing here, laws that would feel threatening to you personally.
是啊。是啊。我想知道你是否有在关注这里的法律变更，那些让你个人感到威胁的法律。
I mean, I think that once you've immigrated once in your life it's always a possibility. So yeah, even though I'm not actively thinking about leaving the United States, it's not a crazy possibility for me. It could happen. Personally, it's complicated because I have kids here, and some of them are semi-grown. So then you start having other kinds of roots.
我的意思是，我认为一旦你这一生移民过一次，这就总是种可能。所以是的，尽管我没有积极考虑离开美国，但这对我来说不是什么疯狂的可能性。它可能会发生。个人而言，这很复杂，因为我有孩子在这里，他们中有些已经半成年了。所以你就开始有了其他形式的根基。
But, for example, and this is not a terribly unlikely scenario, it becomes impossible to get hormone treatment in this country. That, for me, would be a question of my personal health. And I'd probably actually have to leave. Yeah.
但是，举例来说，这是一个不太不可能的场景：在这个国家获得激素治疗变得不可能。对我来说，那将是一个关于我个人健康的问题。我可能真的不得不离开。是的。
When I first started making this show, I imagined it being about leaving all sorts of places, but it's all about the same place-- home, a place you love. If you're lucky, you have some choice in the matter and time to think about it. But it's a choice to break your own heart.
当我第一次开始制作这个节目时，我想象它是关于离开各种各样的地方，但它全是关于同一个地方——家，你热爱的地方。如果你幸运，你对这件事有一点选择和思考的时间。但这是一种破碎自己心脏的选择。
Today's show was produced by Diane Wu and Chris Benderev. The people who put together today's show include Jane Ackermann, Phia Bennin, Zoe Chace, Sean Cole, Michal Comite, Aviva DeKornfeld, Cassie Howley, Valerie Kipnis, Seth Lind, Alaa Mostafa, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Nadia Reiman, Ryan Rumery, Alissa Shipp, Alix Spiegel, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Swetala, Marisa Robertson-Textor, and Matt Tierney.
今天的节目由戴安·吴（Diane Wu）和克里斯·本德雷夫（Chris Benderev）制作。参与制作今天节目的人员包括简·阿克曼（Jane Ackermann）、菲亚·贝宁（Phia Bennin）、佐伊·蔡斯（Zoe Chace）、肖恩·科尔（Sean Cole）、米哈尔·科米特（Michal Comite）、阿维娃·德科恩菲尔德（Aviva DeKornfeld）、卡西·豪利（Cassie Howley）、瓦莱丽·基普尼斯（Valerie Kipnis）、塞思·林德（Seth Lind）、阿拉·穆斯塔法（Alaa Mostafa）、斯托·尼尔森（Stowe Nelson）、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多（Katherine Rae Mondo）、娜迪亚·雷曼（Nadia Reiman）、瑞安·鲁梅里（Ryan Rumery）、阿丽莎·希普（Alissa Shipp）、阿利克斯·斯皮格尔（Alix Spiegel）、莉莉·沙利文（Lilly Sullivan）、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉（Christopher Swetala）、玛丽莎·罗伯逊-泰克斯特（Marisa Robertson-Textor）以及马特·蒂尔尼（Matt Tierney）。
The Managing Editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Senior Editor is David Kestenbaum. Our Executive Editor is Emanuele Berry. Special thanks to Agnieszka Suszko, Kylie Cooper, Wendy Heipt, Leilah Zahedi-Spung, Alireza Shamshirsaz, Alison Block, Kate Connors, Rachel Kingery, Mary Ziegler, David Childs, and Cheryl Strayed.
我们的网站是ThisAmericanLife.org，在那里您可以完全免费收听我们超过750集的档案，再说一遍，ThisAmericanLife.org。
Our website, ThisAmericanLife.org, where you can stream our archive of over 750 episodes for absolutely free, again, ThisAmericanLife.org.
《美国生活》通过公共广播交流中心（PRX）分发给公共广播电台。谢谢，祝我们的老板艾拉·格拉斯生日快乐。我曾见过他因为声音被认出来，有时人们在公众场合认出他并问问题时，他确实心情复杂。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, and happy birthday, Ira, to our boss, Ira Glass. I once saw him get recognized for his voice, and he does have mixed feelings sometimes about the questions people ask when they recognize him in public.
当有人在杂货店走过来问我关于阴道分泌物的问题时，这可不怎么美妙。
When somebody comes up to me in the grocery store and wants to ask a question about vaginal discharge, that's not awesome.
我是南希·厄普代克。欢迎下周继续收听《美国生活》的更多故事。
I'm Nancy Updike. Join us next week for more stories of This American Life.
我是南希·厄普代克。欢迎下周收听更多《美国生活》的故事。